he's the Nevada head basketball coach
Eric Musselman joining us Continental
Tire Coach's Corner coach good morning
congratulations do you have your shirt
on this morning how did this shirt come
off in the first place this feels like
it's a growing tradition for you it is
Dan so really what happened is the first
year I was at Nevada we had we want a
CBI championship and as I was taking my
dress shirt off to put on the
championship t-shirt the guys grabbed me
and picked me up and and it I was
midstream of getting the t-shirt on and
and then it just kind of became a
tradition and I guess because my wife's
really really good-looking I got to try
to say good as I possibly the most
important question you'll probably hear
this week how much can you bench coach I
can bench 225 still no I just in 10
minutes that's my claim to fame in the
workout world I love it when you're down
22 what's the great coaching advice you
give your team really what we tried to
do Dan was just wear every time out
every little meeting that we had we
wanted to try to chip away and the fit
the first thing we said I think it was
around the 11 and a half minute mark we
were down 22 we said hey let's cut this
thing to 15 we you know once we met
again it was like 16 then we got it back
down to single digits and at that point
you know we talked about we had to play
flawless defense and we had to rebound
the ball because you know Cincinnati is
such a great defensive team they're so
physical on the offensive boards and and
we're small and our guys did a great job
you know we really only placed six guys
because of injuries and such and you
know just the toughness that our guys
showed down the stretch and and then we
started making shots and when we play
fast and
temple and and are able to shoot threes
in transition we're a really really good
basketball team in both Texas in the
first game of the NCAA tournament in
Game two
yesterday den Cincinnati those both
those programs controlled the tempo in
the first half and that's why we got
down we could we couldn't get any
offensive rhythm and and luckily for us
both second half's that you know the
tempo changed and that played into our
favor I didn't know if it helped you
being down 14 to Texas you know earlier
in the tournament you know that you're
down 22 against Cincinnati no it
definitely helped then because I think
that you know our guys believed that it
was possible and and last year we were
down I think it was 26 at New Mexico
um and came back and won that game we
were down like 24 with with under 10
minutes to go and I think that you know
because of the Texas because of last
year's New Mexico you know when we say
that we can come back I think now guys
actually believe it we certainly don't
want to put ourselves in this position
continually but you know I'm just proud
that there was no you know quit because
because we were getting you know we were
getting it didn't handed to us the game
Cincinnati controlled every aspect of it
in the first half he's Eric Musselman
Nevada head coach next up Thursday loyal
of Chicago what's the mood like on
campus well you know we're still we're
in Nashville and but the mood on campus
is incredible right right before we got
on with you my son flew back with with
the band and the cheer team and he's
going through the airport in Reno to go
back to Oakland and he goes dad
everybody in the airport's recognizing
me and he was with me last night
postgame and so everybody in Reno was
really pumped up and excited at you know
there's one other time in the program
history that the Wolfpack made it to the
sweet 16 so we're the second team in
school history
do that and so everybody's excited you
know we just I mean to be a part of this
tournament dan is absolutely incredible
having coached in the NBA and nothing's
like this I mean it's it's it's just
absolutely incredible to be part of what
I think is you know the greatest
sporting event in the world we were
running down all of your stops because
people don't realize how much time how
many years the traveling that you have
coaches you know you're constantly
taking jobs we give the audience an idea
of where you've been in the oddest place
that you ended up coaching was where
yeah I bet in so many places but I work
for some great coaches I spent time as
an NBA assistant coach with Chuck Daly
in Orlando work with Lon Kruger as an
assistant coach with the Atlanta Hawks
was the head coach to the Golden State
Warriors and Sacramento Kings was an
assistant coach with Mike fratello with
the Memphis Grizzlies was the national
team coach for Venezuela and the
Dominican Republic I speak zero Spanish
wait wait how do you become the head
coach of Venezuela well in reality I was
first the coach of the Dominican
Republic dance man I had a contract to
come back this is a great store I had a
contract to come back to coach the
following year we had played our way
into the pre Olympics and I was getting
set to go back in a couple months and
coach Calipari called and he said hey
mas can you send me all the tape
I'm the Dominican Republic and can you
do a little write-up on the DR players
and I said what do you mean Callen what
do you need that for and he goes why
McCoach of the Dominican Republic I said
Cal I got a contract in my email wait
you got replaced by coach Cal I got
replaced and nobody told me you could
end up facing him next weekend no I know
trust me I saw the business I first time
I looked at it I started thinking about
I got a 5-minute can Republican here he
can wear his and I can wear mine hey
it's uh it's been great a great run
please tell your wife we set a low and
good luck against loyal to Chicago I
will thanks so much Dan love coming on
appreciation that's Eric Musselman
Nevada head basketball coach they got
loyal to Chicago coming up for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]